what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
we have a new trailer for Guardians of
the Galaxy giving us a new look at Adam
Warlock the high evolutionary and our
Guardians and of course we're going to
break down everything that we saw in
this brand new trailer and there has
even been a new official synopsis
released that gives us a little bit more
insight on what the movie is about and
it helps us clarify some of these scenes
as well so let's first start off with
the synopsis then break down the trailer
it reads in Marvel studios's Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 our beloved band of
Misfits are settling into life on
nowhere now quick pause right here
because if you did not watch the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
you might not know that the Guardians
purchased nowhere from The Collector so
nowhere now belongs to the Guardians of
the Galaxy and that's where their base
is now so the Guardians are sitting all
comfy in nowhere but then the synopsis
continues to read but it isn't long
before their lives are appended by the
echo of rockets turbulent past Peter
Quill still reeling from the loss of
Gamora must rally his team around him on
a dangerous mission to save Rocket's
life a mission that if not completed
successfully could quite possibly lead
to the end of the Guardians as we know
them so this synopsis gets very very
specific and it tells us that the
Guardians are going to have to save
Rocket's life now who do they have to
save Rocket's life from well kind of
three different people as most know in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 rocket
double-crossed The Sovereign he stole
the harbilary batteries from them what
are they called again anilax batteries
Arbor Larry batteries there's nothing
like what I just said
[Laughter]
because he stoled anulax batteries
they're called harbulary batteries oh
there
this resulted in the sovereign's Army
chasing after the Guardians luckily and
also eventually not so luckily ego found
them and helped them out until he
eventually tried to kill them all and
the entire universe but the Sovereign
Was Defeated and this really made Aisha
mad and it made her create a new
specimen Adam and now she is sending
Adam to go and fetch rocket so Aisha
slash The Sovereign and Adam Warlock are
two people that rocket has to worry
about and they really are kind of the
same organization however we're gonna
talk about how Adam Warlock is going to
go away from The Sovereign in just a bit
but the other person that he has to
worry about is the high evolutionary and
this is who I believe actually ends up
with rocket at the end the high
evolutionary is the person who created
rocket against his will maitaiad and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 1 when
rocket was fighting with Drax and the
rest of the Guardians he said I didn't
ask to get made he thinks I'm stupid
think he does well I didn't ask to get
made
I didn't have to be torn apart and put
back together over and over and turned
into some
some little monster rocket no one's
calling you a monster he called me
Furman so the person who tore him apart
and put him back together over and over
again is the high evolutionary who we
see in this trailer and we even get
scenes of Rocket as a baby being
experimented on and just judging by
these scenes and how this movie is kind
of feeling you know it's going to be
super sad so since the Guardians of the
Galaxy have to rescue Rocket Raccoon and
since we find them in this trailer in
the prison of the high evolutionary then
in the high evolutionary space I'm
assuming that the high evolutionary gets
his hands on rocket and is holding
rocket prisoner now the high
evolutionary in the comics is all about
you guessed it Evolution he begins on
Earth as a normal person then he begins
experimenting on animals eventually he
figures out a way to basically evolve
animals to where they are still animals
but are more like humans they can talk
and they can understand language
basically an animal with the brain of a
human now eventually he does end up
leaving Earth with his experiments and
he lands on a planet and creates a place
called counter Earth and looks exactly
like Earth the only difference is his
experiments populated this is what we
saw in the previous trailer where the
Guardians land on an earth they land in
the suburbs but everybody there is
essentially an evolved animal this is
the scene that I believe we see in this
new trailer where the Guardians are
coming upon Earth I don't think it's
actually Earth I think it's counter
Earth and they're looking very strangely
at it because it looks exactly like
Earth but it's a planet very very far
away from Earth now the trailer actually
starts off with a scene with Peter Quill
AKA Star-Lord drinking alone this is
because he is still extremely sad that
the Gamora that he knew and loved died
in Avengers Infinity War Thanos
sacrificed Gamora the one that he loved
for the Soul Stone and yes Gamora is
kind of back but of course she is from
that other timeline the other Thanos
came from in Avengers end game she stuck
around in our timeline and is now based
off of what we saw from previous
trailers that were only showed at San
Diego Comic-Con we know that Gamora is
now the leader of the ravengers so
that's why why we see Gamora with the
Guardians of the Galaxy that's sort of
how they team back up how did this
happen to Gamora how did she become the
leader of a ravenger faction or maybe
the entire thing unsure right now we'll
have to wait and see about that but it
does bring Gamora back into Quill's life
back into all of the Guardians lives but
she is not the same we cut to a scene
where the Guardians are in a prison of
the high evolutionaries Gamora nebula
and Star-Lord are in some type of an
elevator and we know it's the prison of
the high evolutionary because we see one
of his workers there wearing the white
coat Star-Lord explains that he formed
the Guardians he fell in love with
Gamora she died and that she kind of
came back but we know how Star-Lord and
the rest of them seem to feel about this
new Gamora fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it and even nebula
agrees so this Gamora is very different
also side note the very final scene of
this trailer just Gamora quill and
nebula altogether where Gamora says
whoever you are in love with sounds more
like her pointing to nebula the two of
them both say yeah right that would
never happen but then we catch quills
staring at nebula nebula says knock it
off but quill says he never noticed how
black her eyes were she of course
explains that Thanos ripped out her
original eyes and put those in as a form
of torture but quill says he picked a
nice set implying that Star-Lord might
actually kind of be into nebula now I
don't think this is actually going to
happen I don't think Star-Lord and
nebula are going to get together however
I don't think Gamora this new one and
Peter Quill are going to get together
either I don't see the movie ending that
way especially if you consider the fact
that in the comics Adam Warlock and
Gamora got together and they are
introducing Adam Warlock in this movie
now not saying that's gonna happen in
this movie but we know some of the
Guardians of the Galaxy are sticking
around and a new team team is going to
be formed most likely with Adam Warlock
on it and if Gamora sticks around and
she probably will because she's a leader
of ravengers she'll also be on that team
and Star-Lord probably isn't going to be
on that team so Adam and Gamora will be
together so that might happen down the
road and I'm not even sure Star-Lord is
going to survive this film now the
prison that they're in you may notice it
looks kind of weird and this is due to
the experiments of the high evolutionary
the building seems to be somewhat
combined with flesh so this is a
definite experiment from the high
evolutionary now in this trailer we see
the Guardians kind of fighting to break
out of this prison and I actually think
we can kind of see the scene where Drax
gets shot through his chest if you take
a look at this scene at one minute 32
seconds we can see Drax throws somebody
really far he then raises his arms and
yells but behind him to his left we see
one of the security people of the prison
with a giant gun in his hand the next
scene that we see is the Guardians
carrying Drax out of the the prison with
a huge hole in his chest so I'm pretty
sure that this guard in the background
when Drax is celebrating simply just
shoots him from behind now this scene is
most likely not towards the very end and
we do see Drax in scenes in the trailer
that do kind of seem like they are
towards the end so I don't think he
actually dies here however I do think he
is going to die in the film now we do
have a scene where Adam Warlock is on
counter Earth he is flying through the
suburbs that look a lot like regular
Earth looking for rocket and in this
scene we actually see Gamora running
away with a hurt rocket in her hand we
also have a scene that shows Groot
jumping on Adam Warlock trying to fight
him as well now Marvel Studios did come
out and tell us that Adam Warlock is
essentially going to be like a child in
the movie after all in this movie he's
basically going to be kind of just born
from his cocoon now since he was made in
a cocoon he obviously grows faster or
they made him simply as an adult however
his mind Marvel confirmed is still very
very much like a child he is still
learning a lot of things so right now
The Sovereign has Adam Warlock searching
for rocket and the Guardians of the
Galaxy however I think as the movie goes
on and he learns and he gets to know the
Guardians a little bit more he's going
to turn good because Adam Warlock is a
good guy for the most part in the comics
now I've had the same theory for a very
long time that the high evolutionary is
actually created The Sovereign The
Sovereign is all about Evolution and
that's what the high evolutionary is
about so The Sovereign could be getting
Rocket Raccoon or the high evolutionary
and Adam Warlock could capture rocket
and then deliver him to the high
evolutionary and that's how all of these
different parties The Sovereign High
evolutionary out of more luck in the
Guardians all kind of come together and
are all connected by the end of the film
but again I think by the end of the film
Adam Warlock is going to turn good and
he's going to help the Guardians defeat
The Sovereign and the high evolutionary
now one final note it is worth noting
that the high evolutionary does
experiment on himself as well as we can
see here in these trailers there are
some scenes where he kind of looks like
he's a half man half machine the back
half of his head is missing and what I'm
assuming is happening here is when we
see him where his head looks normal
those are flashbacks to where he
experimented on rocket and the other
animals like we see his girlfriend Lila
in this trailer as well and she has a
robotic arm so I think these scenes are
in the past even though we do know that
rocket and Lila are going to reunite
together again in this film and
hopefully that is Rocket's happy ending
he doesn't die but he gets to go and
live his life with Lila but like I said
sadly we do know that some of the
Guardians are probably going to die if
you have any predictions be sure to let
us know yours in the comments down below
I'm thinking that Drax dies and possibly
Star-Lord but not too sure about the
Star-Lord so let us know your thoughts
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof